Vous souvenez-vous
des PREMIERS MOTS
que vous avez entendus aujourd’hui ?
Pythagore a dit :
« Le commencement
est LA MOITIÉ
de tout.
»
« Les hommes mangent trois fois par jours
depuis la nuit des temps :
il y a le petit-déjeuner,
le déjeuner,
et le dîner.
»
Ah bah,
c’est pas de chance :
c’est faux !
Bon,
je vais pas en faire cinquante
non plus !
Il y a plein de manières DIFFÉRENTES
de capter l’attention ;
il existe différentes techniques
pour INTÉRESSER
une personne
à ce que vous allez lui dire.
Et que ça soit
dans les interactions humaines,
dans un discours,
ou,
encore plus spécifiquement,
dans une dissertation,
vous devez ACCROCHER
la personne
à laquelle vous vous adressez.
À quoi est-ce que ça sert une accroche,
ou une amorce,
en dissertation ?
Ça sert à INTÉRESSER
le correcteur.
Bien sûr,
il vous lira de toute façon,
puisqu’il est payé pour
— MAIS
il sera MIEUX DISPOSÉ
à votre égard,
si vous RÉUSSISSEZ
votre accroche.
Vous avez donc intérêt
à la soigner.
Je sais que certains profs recommandent
de NE PAS
faire d’accroche.
Moi,
je ne suis pas d’accord,
MAIS ce conseil n’est pas stupide,
parce qu’il est difficile de rédiger
une BONNE accroche
— ENFIN,
c’est difficile pour TOUS CEUX
qui n’auront pas vu cette vidéo,
mais si vous regardez cette vidéo jusqu’à
la fin,
ça sera bien moins difficile.
En fait,
TOUT sera difficile en dissertation
pour ceux
qui ne se seront pas préparés
avec mon cours GRATUIT
de méthodologie de la dissertation.
Inscrivez-vous donc pour le recevoir :
le lien doit s’afficher maintenant en haut
à droite,
mais vous pouvez aussi trouver le lien
dans la description de la vidéo.
C’est un cours par e-mail,
donc vous pouvez d’abord
regarder cette vidéo entièrement,
puis vous découvrirez
mes techniques de méthodologie
juste après,
ou bien dans les prochains jours.
Maintenant,
j’ai une question pour vous :
POURQUOI
est-ce que vous DEVEZ
rédiger une accroche ?
PARCE QUE
dans l’introduction de la dissertation,
après l’accroche,
il y a la définition des termes ;
et que donc,
si vous ne faites pas d’accroche,
eh bien
LA PREMIÈRE CHOSE
que lit le correcteur,
c’est la définition des termes !
C’est-à-dire le passage
LE PLUS CHIANT
de la dissertation !
C’est comme si la première chose
que je vous disais,
c’est ce qu’il y a
sur ma carte d’identité :
Romain Treffel,
né en France,
yeux marrons,
etc.
Ça donne pas envie !
Alors,
c’est vrai que si vous n’avez vraiment
AUCUNE IDÉE
pour l’accroche,
il vaut peut-être mieux
ne PAS FAIRE
d’accroche,
plutôt que de faire mauvaise impression
dès le début de la dissertation
avec une accroche maladroite.
MAIS SI
vous avez bien préparé
votre épreuve de dissertation,
SI
vous avez regardé cette vidéo jusqu’au
bout,
il n’y a pas de raison :
vous SAUREZ
rédiger une BONNE accroche.
Je vais maintenant vous révéler
les CINQ
types d’accroches possibles en dissertation.
Restez jusqu’à la fin
parce qu’à mon avis…
vous ne connaissez pas le cinquième,
et il va vous étonner.
Le PREMIER type d’accroche possible
— et le plus courant —
c’est d’introduire une référence,
comme vous le feriez dans un paragraphe
du développement de votre dissertation.
Cette accroche sert à CAPTER
l’attention du correcteur
en évoquant une idée intéressante
et en invoquant l’autorité intellectuelle
d’un auteur.
Alors,
il faut bien sûr que l’idée soit à la
fois
PERTINENTE
— c’est-à-dire qu’elle soit bien
en rapport avec l’énoncé —
et il faut aussi qu’elle soit INTÉRESSANTE,
comme je l’ai déjà dit.
Je vous donne un exemple.
J’ai commencé ma dissertation sur le sujet
« Philosopher,
est-ce apprendre à mourir ? »
par la phrase suivante :
« Dans son Histoire de la philosophie,
Julian Marias considère que seule la métaphysique
mérite le nom de « philosophie ». »
Là,
grosso modo,
je dis qu’un historien de la philosophie
répondrait NON
à la question de l’énoncé.
D’après Julian Marias,
la philosophie
ce n’est pas apprendre à mourir,
mais découvrir
la vérité sur notre monde.
Mon accroche est bien sûr pertinente,
puisque c’est une réponse
à la question de l’énoncé ;
et elle est aussi INTÉRESSANTE,
parce que c’est une référence plutôt
originale,
et aussi un point de vue tranché.
Une fois que vous avez présenté la référence
en une phrase CLAIRE,
comme la mienne,
vous devez encore APPROFONDIR l’idée
sur une deux phrases.
Si son rapport avec l’énoncé n’est pas
évident,
vous devez l’expliquer davantage.
Allez,
on passe au deuxième type d’accroche !
Le DEUXIÈME type d’accroche
— qui est le plus « classe »
entre guillemets —
c’est de citer un auteur.
Vous vous souvenez d’une formule
en rapport avec l’énoncé,
eh bien vous commencez votre dissertation
par cette formule.
Comme pour le premier type d’accroche,
il faut bien sûr que l’IDÉE de la citation
soit à la fois PERTINENTE
et INTÉRESSANTE.
Ça c’est important,
parce que je sais
que les élèves aiment bien
écrire des citations
parce qu’ils pensent
que ça va impressionner le correcteur.
MAIS la plupart du temps,
la citation n’est pas très pertinente,
donc elle ne produit PAS
un bon effet.
Conclusion :
ne cherchez pas à tout prix
à caser une citation ;
choisissez ce type d’accroche
UNIQUEMENT
si l’idée vous semble
ÉVIDEMMENT
pertinente
par rapport à l’énoncé.
Je vous donne un exemple.
J’aurais pu commencer ma dissertation sur
le sujet
« Philosopher,
est-ce apprendre à mourir ? »
par cette citation
des Lettres à Lucilius de Sénèque :
« Savoir mourir est la seule chose
qu’un jour on exigera forcément de nous.
»
L’idée est pertinente
parce qu’elle traite de la mort
et parce que Sénèque est un philosophe ;
et elle est aussi INTÉRESSANTE
parce qu’elle est un peu radicale
(Sénèque dit que savoir mourir
est LA SEULE CHOSE
qu’on exigera de nous).
Comme pour le premier type d’accroche,
vous devez encore DÉVELOPPER l’idée
sur une deux phrases.
Allez,
on continue :
type d’accroche
numéro trois !
Le TROISIÈME type d’accroche
est peut-être le plus « accrocheur » :
c’est raconter
une ANECDOTE.
Bah oui,
c’est « accrocheur »
parce que les hommes ADORENT
les histoires !
Bien sûr,
l’accroche doit toujours être PERTINENTE,
mais une bonne anecdote,
ça implique plus particulièrement
DEUX choses :
ce que vous racontez doit être
un minimum curieux,
c’est-à-dire que ça doit
ÉTONNER
le correcteur
— pour le dire plus simplement,
l’histoire ne doit pas être BANALE ;
et la seconde chose,
c’est que vous devez raconter
quelque chose de PRÉCIS.
Donc pas de
« De tout temps... »,
ou
« Dans l’histoire humaine... »
— au contraire,
vous devez raconter
que TELLE personne
a fait TELLE chose
à TELLE époque.
Je vais vous donner un exemple sur le sujet
« Philosopher,
est-ce apprendre à mourir ? ».
Ce serait peut-être difficile pour un étudiant
de trouver une anecdote pertinente
sur ce sujet,
mais j’ai une idée :
je peux raconter
avec quelle sérénité
Socrate a bu le poison
lors de l’exécution
de sa peine de mort.
Voici comment je commencerais ma dissertation
avec cette anecdote :
« Lorsque le gardien-chef de la prison
a signalé que le moment était venu,
Socrate n’a pas hésité :
il a pris la coupe
et il a bu la ciguë sans trembler.
Cette confiance dans le passage à l’acte
laisse à penser
qu’il était prêt à mourir.
»
En général,
vous aurez besoin de deux trois phrases
pour présenter une anecdote,
parce que ce n’est pas simplement une idée
comme dans les types d’accroches précédents
— là vous avez besoin de RACONTER
un fait,
il y a PLUSIEURS
actions à décrire,
donc ça sera probablement plus clair
en PLUSIEURS phrases.
Ce type d’accroche est certes
plus « ACCROCHEUR »,
MAIS il demande aussi
une plus grande culture générale.
Allez,
on passe
au quatrième type d’accroche !
Le QUATRIÈME type d’accroche
possible en dissertation,
c’est d’invoquer
un fait d’actualité récent.
Le PRINCIPE
de ce type d’accroche,
c’est de capter l’attention du lecteur
en lui montrant
que le problème
dont il est question dans la dissertation
est TOUJOURS d’actualité
— ce qui implique qu’en lisant la dissertation,
il pourra MIEUX COMPRENDRE
le monde dans lequel il vit.
C’est la connexion que vous opérez
entre le PRÉSENT CONCRET
et le monde des idées
— c’est cette connexion
qui permet de capter l’attention du lecteur.
Alors,
je vais vous donner un exemple tout de suite
pour que vous compreniez
ce que je veux dire par
« fait d’actualité récente ».
Sur le sujet
« Philosopher,
est-ce apprendre à mourir ? »,
ça serait trop difficile,
et par conséquent trop risqué
— donc je vais choisir un autre sujet.
Voici comment je commencerais une dissertation
sur le sujet
« Travailler moins,
est-ce vivre mieux ? » :
« Le confinement de 2020
a entraîné de nombreux Français
à interroger le sens
de leur activité professionnelle.
»
Cette accroche montre au correcteur
que la question du lien
entre le travail et le bonheur
est très actuelle.
Une seule phrase,
ça serait un peu court,
donc j’expliquerais encore
l’ACTUALITÉ de la question
sur une deux phrases.
Alors,
ce type d’accroche est plutôt « ACCROCHEUR
»
lui aussi,
mais il présente deux risques.
Le premier,
c’est le risque de la vulgarité.
Il ne faut PAS
que le fait d’actualité que vous présentez
donne l’impression
que vous retenez UNIQUEMENT
les informations superficielles,
et que vous êtes incapable
d’aller en profondeur.
Par exemple,
il ne faut pas évoquer en accroche
un scandale politique récent,
ou une petite phrase
qu’aurait dite un homme politique,
et qui est dans tous les esprits
pendant une semaine.
Ce qu’il faut,
c’est que le correcteur puisse comprendre
FACILEMENT
que le fait d’actualité
illustre,
ou révèle,
une question PROFONDE.
Le second risque de ce type d’accroche,
c’est le parti pris.
En présentant le fait d’actualité,
vous ne devez pas dire du mal,
ou dire du bien,
d’une action,
d’une parole,
d’une personne,
d’une idée,
etc.
Vous devez rester
le plus NEUTRE possible ;
vous devez rester FACTUEL,
un peu comme un journaliste.
Même si vous êtes un être humain,
et même si l’objectivité n’existe pas,
l’idéal c’est de présenter
un fait AVÉRÉ,
en dépouillant votre description de ce fait
de toute INTERPRÉTATION.
Ce type d’accroche peut sembler facile,
parce qu’on vit dans un monde
où l’information est surabondante,
mais vous l’avez compris,
SÉLECTIONNER
et PRÉSENTER
un fait d’actualité
pour en faire
une BONNE accroche de dissertation,
ce n’est pas facile.
Allez,
on passe au cinquième et DERNIER
type d’accroche.
Le CINQUIÈME type d’accroche
possible en dissertation,
c’est de donner un chiffre,
ou une statistique si vous voulez.
Ce type d’accroche est particulièrement
« ACCROCHEUR »
parce que les données chiffrées
portent en elles
L’AUTORITÉ
de la science.
Autrement dit,
quand on lit une statistique,
on a l’impression
que c’est la vérité VRAIE
— bien sûr,
la statistique peut être fausse,
ou ne pas vouloir dire grand chose,
être sujette à interprétation,
MAIS en général
nous tombons dans le piège,
parce que nous sommes très sensibles
à l’autorité intellectuelle
qui émane des chiffres,
et c’est pour ça
que nous aimons les statistiques.
Alors,
je ne vous dis pas d’inventer des chiffres
pour séduire le correcteur ;
je ne vous dis pas non plus
que toutes les statistiques ne valent rien.
Au contraire,
moi j’aime bien donner des chiffres en accroche
:
je trouve ça intéressant
et original.
MAIS
si vous voulez le faire sérieusement,
vous devez respecter DEUX CONDITIONS
— en plus de la pertinence,
bien sûr.
Voici les deux conditions :
votre statistique doit être PRÉCISE,
et SOURCÉE.
Je vous montre comment faire
avec un exemple.
Voici comment je pourrais commencer une dissertation
sur le sujet
« Travailler moins,
est-ce vivre mieux ? » :
« D’après un sondage Ifop de 2016,
75 % des Français
se disent heureux au travail.
»
Ma statistique est PRÉCISE :
je n’ai pas écrit « une majorité de Français
»,
j’ai donné le chiffre exact du sondage.
Ma statistique est également SOURCÉE :
j’ai donné le nom de l’institut de sondage
qui a produit l’étude,
et j’ai précisé l’année de l’étude.
MAIS si je commence ma dissertation
en écrivant :
« D’après les sondages,
plus de la moitié des Français
sont heureux au travail. »,
là c’est trop IMPRÉCIS.
Ça passerait probablement au Bac
— mais bon,
tout passe au Bac —
ça passerait certainement au Bac,
mais un correcteur de concours
ne s’en satisferait pas.
Il veut un résultat PRÉCIS,
et il veut savoir D’OÙ VIENT
ce résultat précis.
Ce sont ces exigences
qui rendent ce dernier type d’accroche
plus difficile à rédiger
que les autres.
En résumé,
vous pouvez utiliser CINQ
types d’accroches
en dissertation :
vous pouvez introduire une référence,
comme vous le feriez
dans un paragraphe du développement ;
vous pouvez écrire une citation ;
raconter une anecdote ;
un fait d’actualité ;
et enfin,
vous pouvez donner une statistique.
Je vous recommande de privilégier
les TROIS
premiers types d’accroches,
parce que les deux derniers,
le fait d’actualité
et la statistique,
ces deux types d’accroches
sont plus difficiles à rédiger.
Souvenez-vous aussi
que votre accroche doit toujours
être PERTINENTE
et relativement PRÉCISE.
Vous voulez tester des accroches ?
Eh bien écrivez-les
dans les commentaires,
et je vous dirai ce que j’en pense.
Après,
n’accordez pas trop d’importance à l’accroche,
parce que ce n’est pas ESSENTIEL
pour réussir une dissertation.
Ce qu’il vous faut
pour réussir vos dissertations,
c’est une méthodologie SOLIDE.
Je vous invite donc
à vous inscrire pour recevoir
mon cours GRATUIT
de méthodologie de la dissertation
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
soit en utilisant celui
qui est dans la description de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
j’espère que cette vidéo vous a plu,
et puis qu’elle vous sera utile.
Je suis Romain,
je suis toujours avec mon fidèle Haristote,
et vous étiez
sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous
que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête
pour réussir
les accroches de vos dissertations.